Adam McKay who I admire greatly and
who's one of the funniest humans alive
we had a meeting we're sitting there
talking he said how would you like to
how would you like to do a feature film
in four days and I went I liked that
idea and then he said how would you like
to play Donald Trump and I loved that
idea I didn't care if I knew if I was
capable or not I wanted to try so yeah
so I I did my bit is Donald Trump you
don't want to be Donald Trump because
he's the way he speaks is very specific
yeah
were you telling all the Mexicans to get
off set I told them to build me that
wall
I want a sensational wall fabulous wall
I don't remember what the question was
but doesn't matter because I'm not gonna
answer it anyway
I walk over at this point I write oh god
maybe he won't remember me would be
humiliated was it to pee in can't do any
form of bathroom like the guys who made
it we're like when she's a girl she
doesn't go to the bathroom so I standing
up